hi guys first of all I want to just
thank you for all your amazing results
that you're getting from doing in a
minute fasting and ketosis I read all
your comments mind-blowing so well done
keep going on that had some questions
recently about should I do a one meal a
day type pattern so let's just talk
about that so socially we're just not
set up to do in a minute fasting I mean
you're what are you go out to dinner
with your friends and sit there not
eating anything so it is difficult in
our culture and the current eating model
that we're stuck in is based on running
your body on blood sugar it's all about
trying to keep your blood Sugar's up so
it's take the snack eat this food have
this meal so yes there's certain people
that will say well the reason why you're
gonna lose weight on one meal a day is
simply because of calories but there's
more to that so I want to cover that so
the difference between in a minute
fasting and a low calorie diet really
has to do with the frequency of eating
and making sure you get your nutrients
so you're not actually starving so I do
recommend you supplement with the B
vitamins minerals trace minerals
wheatgrass juice powder works really
really good on that but the point is you
don't want to start consuming less
nutrients and your hair start falling
out and getting tired so many people
start with three meals a day and then
they go down to two meals a day and then
they're just not hungry so they go to
one meal a day and they feel so much
better cognitive function energy so I'm
gonna just let you test the waters and
see how you feel but you're gonna be
surprised like your energy level and
your cognitive function in your memory
and the mental clarity is just amazing
and that's simply because fat is a much
more efficient fuel okay so you're
running your body on this fat and it's a
cleaner fuel and then when you eat it
actually stimulates insulin which kind
of can give you a little brain fog so
I'll let you decide what you want to do
but the point is that you're also going
to have other benefits too and one of
the biggest benefits is a toughie G what
is a tappa G Tavo G is your body's
ability to recycle old cellular parts it
also will clean up mold viruses bacteria
fungus in the cell and clean all that up
now what do you think is going to happen
if you're going to clean all this old
waste out of your body you're gonna feel
you're gonna look better your brain
cells your cognitive your immune system
your inflammation is going to come way
down and just I mean just the amount of
people that have inflammation I mean
it's incredible
I'll stiff they are and all of a sudden
they do this and they start loosening up
they feel better
inflammation goes down the swelling and
the legs goes down so it's that's why
they're just feeling better it's but
it's blood sugars it's burning your fat
and then a toffee gene also intermittent
fasting really is good for your
metabolism it fixes in insulin and
resistance and that's what's really
behind that hitting that set point where
you just can't seem to drop lower with
your weight and you just hover run a
certain weight that's called insulin
resistance and this will fix it so
especially one male in day but again I
would recommend starting in three meals
a day two meals a day do it for a while
until you feel comfortable until you
have no more hunger and then try one
meal a day okay so you're gonna find
that you may like this and it might work
for you and lastly I want to cover three
things number one the quality of food
you don't want to do one meal a day
eating junk food
make sure it's high quality number two
the quantity of food needs to be a lot
higher now the difficulty is how do you
cram in three meals in one meal it's
going to be very difficult you're gonna
have to enhance your diet with
supplements but try to eat as much as
you can and high-quality foods
especially vegetables some protein and
high quality fats
last thing is when do you do this well
it really doesn't matter just pick a
time it can vary through the day it
doesn't have to be at the same time all
right
some people do an evening some people do
in the morning some people do in the
middle of the day all right so put your
comments below and tell me what you
think so Karen and I are going to create
some more recipes but we wanted to know
what recipes are you interested in okay
click the link and let us know